thank you
[Music]
you World Cup fan you're a football
soccer fan
it's a football in Spanish but soccer I
say soccer yeah because you know I'm
also [ __ ] American dude
they're cool
all right cool it's American so um this
way or is it this way it's [ __ ] any
way you want do you know why any way you
want you know why because this America
some [ __ ] all right go ahead so there's
a a bunch of people that always try to
you know illegally stream certain
sporting events or things and I salute
those people yeah Americans dude let me
tell you dude I live off I lived off of
LimeWire for the biggest [ __ ] time
dude so I'm all about that shikaza all
day every day because all day every day
the real ones know because I like even
oh [ __ ] so uh
usually sometimes when you stream
illegally things they don't come in
[ __ ] 4K HD like the streaming service
sometimes there's like make do with what
you got yeah
people sometimes pop out of the movie
screen
that's fine you know I bought this movie
at a [ __ ] swap meet school so we'll
say thousands of viewers were uh
watching the World Cup 22 in Qatar on
illegal streams but in reality what they
were streaming was pixelated FIFA 23
games that's funny that's funny
pixelated hey 23 games okay so they
actually got me they actually got me on
one of these because on YouTube because
I like sometimes when I didn't catch the
game I went on YouTube and I saw the
highlights and I started looking I was
like wait a minute this is a FIFA game
because they were like saying oh that
happened to you yeah they have like like
uh I think it was a Argentina versus uh
Poland it said it was like seven eight
to one and I'm like no wait and I looked
at it I was like wait a minute
this is a FIFA game I zoomed in and I
was like wait a minute the name pops up
and everything I was like this is a
[ __ ] FIFA game so they got me yep so
more than even is that how good the
graphics are they are pretty good yes
they're really really good yeah 2023 is
[ __ ] pretty good dude but they do an
extra job about it so for example more
than 40 000 people in France alone fell
for this trick which involved illegal
streaming sites linking to YouTube
channels which were committing replays
of FIFA 23 matches but using headlines
such as live Germany Japan on 2311 group
E World Cup 2022 look that's all they
got me bud so they'll put live tickers
yeah and the funny thing is they're um
every single time people were streaming
into these things they had Vietnamese
commentary it's just [ __ ] random
Vietnamese [ __ ] right so people who jump
into these streams actually believe that
they're actual like they're pulling the
real game from another host country
which is why they're feeling like this
is real but I think the [ __ ] funniest
part about this is the people who are
putting these I'm like why would you put
in the work control right so is it just
a troll or is it because you're making
money off your Twitch stream whoa so
these people who are duping other people
are making money off of their game plan
thousands tens of thousands of people
are watching them play FIFA 23. dude
they're streaming and making a lot of
streaming sites that I may or may not
use they always run tons of ads on there
so they'll probably get tons of AD
Revenue dude this guy's a genius imagine
giving him a Rayman chip
it's gonna be dangerous jumping over
buildings there's no limit of that guy
dude that's a neural link video that's
not going to be linked right here yeah
it went from a [ __ ] human to a genie
real [ __ ] quick dude that's crazy can
I see what they look like you want to
see a FIFA you already got duped to buy
one yeah but I want to see if this is
the maybe it's the same guy there's no
link the actual stream here took my
[ __ ] money dude
I should have known it was a a FIFA game
because he when they made a goal he went
like this threw himself in the floor I'm
like wait a minute I know that's here
yeah the animation that's cool that you
stream illegal stuff though no just
allegedly somebody's got yeah
look at that wink and uh and Bart's
makeup stories you know how Bart has a
wild imagination I remember we try to do
it on her phone
hey DM me for links
allegedly Barbara was hosting one of
these fights one of these days and for
some reason we just kept trying to
Pirate that [ __ ] last minute and it kept
going off and freezing oh that's the
worst and then finally we decided to buy
it or something and then it was like
getting loaded with too many people at
the same time I forgot which fight it
was but it was probably a big one then
yeah because I think I actually tried to
buy it and I think the bot one didn't
work so I was like oh might as well
pirate it because the power one was
working better oh that sucks yeah I
pirate the only fights I ever like did
that too was uh the Jake Paul ones
that's really good pirate all those
games yeah I prepare all day every day
because no one's buying those
pay-per-views no but then you're also
interested like that's like [ __ ] that
I'm not gonna pay for that [ __ ] but then
you're like I want to know yeah yeah
yeah but I don't know what happens yeah
so how do I do this it's probably one of
the most pirated fights for sure because
everybody didn't care but cared enough
you see that's all they got me this
isn't one of the illegal streams but
this is a 4K stream of FIFA uh 23. you
can't even tell oh
wow that does look real dude oh it's
fake I got excited [ __ ] it right now
when they zoom in like that that made it
fake yeah when you look at the crowd
you're like everyone's gonna be the same
dude these Graphics are crazy damn
there's a PS5 yes dude
oh yeah dude
my [ __ ] side note dude I'm a beast
and FIFA dude yeah I think I gotta
understand soccer a little bit more to
know why like people be running back and
forth and it's like why is it exciting
there's no point I totally agree
um but sitting what
on the World Cup finally something
actually [ __ ] I actually felt the
Jitters because once you go into like
penalty kick or something like that
right and then you got [ __ ] a guy
who's kicking and you know the weight of
it and and the announcer is like the
entire nation is on this man yeah that's
that's a big deal and you're talking
like that like literally if this guy
misses it the whole country is knocked
out for the year oh it's the story yeah
dude you're like holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
Mexico game dude when they [ __ ] the
penalty kick and then the guy blocks it
the Mexican goalie blocks it was huge
for us at the place where I was watching
it at the taco place don't don't be
racist
all right I see his [ __ ] eyes light
up
so take it easy part everybody went
[ __ ] nuts dude I'm talking I didn't
even know like I don't like yeah I think
that's why I got sick dude because
everybody was touching grabbing we were
all out but that is such a wild feeling
that like you know an entire you know
like the Olympics especially with
something like the World Cup So Many
Nations actually get you guys don't like
the rock level are we I haven't really
watched
it I I watch zero games
I just know Japan won what's your guys
watch every man dude
but every single time there's a fighter
it's literally only one fighter per
country yeah yeah I can see that and
then every single time you fight it's
like if you got knocked out you're
knocked out for the whole [ __ ] year
I'm talking about the game like I'm with
Joe on the game of soccer you know like
easy dude like Steve for example right
don't watch [ __ ] easy dude I don't
want to bring this guy out right like
what's the point of because I get the
point of a casual basketball game I
could sit at the park and watch people
playing I get what's happening yeah but
then when they're just watching like
five people try to move the ball and
just keep running back and forth all
right dude I gotta understand that you
guys push again prior to my recent
understanding of things and the
intensity that I started learning about
watching a world stage okay let me say
so can I say say something please all
right please I'm not about to say
something dude all right look oh
so have you ever played soccer yeah yeah
it's really fun Have you ever you know
how hard it is to play yeah so when you
watch the Players do certain tricks
they're like [ __ ] that [ __ ] that's what
you love the game the tricks don't come
as often also have you ever watched
European soccer that is the next level
that is like the most if you're gonna
watch soccer do you like it watch the
European soccer okay that [ __ ] is gonna
change the game for you like the way
that they move up watching little league
soccer the MSL is like it's like that's
all right it's getting there but if you
watch European [ __ ] soccer dude it's
like like well Real Madrid okay it's the
highest level Chelsea PSG all these guys
are playing at this level that's just
like the best of the best it's [ __ ]
dope it's like watching golf hey sis can
I ask you something else no it's very
like watching a golfer it was boring to
me as Fox I never liked golf but now
that I play golf I'm like I appreciate
every swing they take and you're okay
how they got it right there I respect
the game more can I can I see something
yeah please yes I I think soccer is a
really great sport it's tight but but no
no I'm not gonna say anything crazy dude
no you can't do that Zara Kinja dude
okay okay but like sometimes I think
what takes me out of soccer sometimes is
the outfits no I love the outfits I wish
the shorts were higher the fact that
they got Spanx and it's holding down the
[ __ ] massive donger you know what I
mean and the quads is like sometimes
when there's like when they try to get
fouls oh yeah yeah and they play that
[ __ ] that's like basketball
they're like [ __ ] big ass dudes
looking oh [ __ ] but some of them in
soccer I'm just like bro like this is
this it takes me out of it sometimes
yeah it's a little too dramatic like I'm
like bro what is this but we even see
that in the MMA
but he's still getting punched in the
face though yeah I mean it's a little
different even in boxing I get you dude
but there's always gonna be a crybaby
somebody sounds biased over there no no
no but it's like even in NBA I hate it
so I'm like it takes me out of the game
too you know what takes me out of NBA
that pisses me off is the talking of the
refs it's two things right
is when they do these like slam dunk
yeah and they go crazy and it's like bro
he's six now
hey hey hey my guy he's supposed to dunk
LeBron is supposed to dunk he's that big
you see a [ __ ] guy like shagging like
holy [ __ ] shackles over there boom oh
[ __ ] it's offensive it's high off the
ground he's like he's just like yeah
it's like me lowering the court to my
like height and just start [ __ ] okay
I thought it's cool so you're supposed
to my guys yeah if he was five two and
he was dunking then I would be like holy
yeah if I'm dunking I understand the
[ __ ] holy [ __ ] aspect but he's big
what's the number two
yeah the number two I think that the
cheering was number two but I did it all
in one
this is it number two was like I don't
like the dramatic cheering on the side
the sidelines it's actually my favorite
oh
yeah do something lukewarm but because
everyone's like this yeah I like that
part I like it also I'm like hey guy you
don't even have a jersey on the [ __ ] are
you cheering I would be pissed I would
go I wouldn't even be at the game go to
the gym get better to get in the game
what are you doing it doesn't happen she
has a suit on and she's like oh [ __ ]
bro you don't like the reactions of the
of the I don't like the bench players
dude getting [ __ ] hyped up and start
with the towel and just go getting
handshakes and [ __ ] dude it's like [ __ ]
the handshakes get in the game I like
the best what are we doing I like it for
the reaction sorry guys you know you
don't spending a wild sport that I
recently watched uh during a break in
the world cup that I was like well this
Sport's [ __ ] crazy which one women's
rugby women where's rugby dude have you
seen how they bleeds on their mountains
that's not just it's not rockets and I'm
just like bro women's rugby I was
walking to New Zealand
I'm sorry dude hey beanie man I'm
[ __ ] sorry guys what [ __ ] nothing
gives me a Roundup than a [ __ ] bloody
nose on a woman like oh [ __ ] oh
he's a dirty [ __ ]
[Music]